[Musik]
dort wo es aus dem boden raucht und
unter der erde kocht dort wo die natur
so schön und grausam zugleich ist dort
steht der künstler roman signer
neben seinem freund jimmy magnusson und
macht sich ein geburtstagsgeschenk zum
eine aktion ins land ganz für sich
allein
arango ein gestocher so oder
[Musik]
ich begleite roman signer auf seiner
reise quer durchs land den mann aus dem
appenzell den die kunstwelt zu füßen
liegt
[Musik]
die geschichte beginnt in der st galler
innenstadt in rom an sieben dass trotz
burg von hier aus plant er den ausbruch
in die freiheit
und so kommt es mir vor auch aus der
enge der schweiz ebenso so lavafelder
torwart mit dem mofa in der nacht sich
irgendwie 1 1 am kalterer landschaft und
hirsch eine erschütternd größe und man
sich größere häuser und dann führte mich
in sein atelier wo er die reise weiter
vorbereitet eigentlich will er noch
nicht viel verraten nur dass es mit
einem schwarzen regenschirm zu tun hat
also mit deiner recker schirm dem
geistig oder den ort besonders der
besonders in der kritik rohstoffe das
thema platz sind diagonal
zurück bleiben die anderen requisiten
auch die raketen lässt da zeugen von
vergangenen aktionen
[Musik]
roman signer gilt als einer der großen
zeitgenössischen schweizer künstler
zunächst als sprengmeister der nation
verschrien
seit den 90er jahren jedoch
international hoch gehandelt sein werk
lebt von absurden momenten das
schmunzeln ist teil des plans
[Musik]
seine kunst spiegelt zum teil in island
etwa im film siegen als koffer der vor
20 jahren erschienen ist
roman signer hier mit seinem assistenten
thomas rogoß reist seit 20 jahren
regelmäßig in den hohen norden
ganz im osten der insel wartet die
messer auf die beiden
er ist auch künstler und daneben
kunstprofessor
seit 20 jahren erkunden sie island
magnusson gilt als kenner der insel
es ist ende mai und es hat kräftig
geschneit die passstrasse auf 500 meter
über meer wurde am tag zuvor gesperrt
[Musik]
am fjord hinter dem pass liegt das dorf
sei dies war weit weg von der hauptstadt
leben hier 700 einwohner
darunter schriftsteller und künstler
am rand des dorfes haben die beiden
freunde vor acht jahren ein altes
fischer aus gekauft und renoviert
ein sommerhaus am ende der welt
wir verbringen die beiden künstler mit
ihren familien die ferien ein stück
heimat für den isländer für den
vielbeschäftigten schweizer ein
möglicher rückzugsort irgendwas scharf
verurteilt ja aber das muss ja keine
großen hitze schuld das kühlt das man
das hätten die wir mal so wir brauchen
also schon wirklich treibt ein fluchtort
[Musik]
man ist froh mann kennenlernte
bewunderte ich natürlich seine arbeiten
aber es war auch interessant ihn
persönlich kennenzulernen
er ist nicht nur ein intelligenter mann
sondern in seiner art ein guter mensch
der mann aus dem appenzell hatte erst
spät mit 35 zur kunst gefunden und
entsprechend spät komme auch die
anerkennung seiner kunst nun zum 75
geburtstag plant wo man siegner seine
aktion will dafür mit to me magnusson
quer durchs land reisen
die haben sich ja wirklich zwei gefunden
denke ich mir beide zurückhaltend
verschlossen
ich glaube künstler sind keine egoisten
es funktioniert sehr gut
er schaffte ganz anders wie oder was ist
ob so möglich nein nein gut
bevor die beiden auf die große reise
gehen wollen sie mir etwas zeigen dass
es nur hier in diesem abgeschiedenen
dorf im osten der insel gibt die
magnusson der isländer dessen vorfahren
schon hier lebten hat für roma einen
museumsbesuch organisiert und spätestens
jetzt wird mir klar dass ich es hier
nicht mit touristen zu tun habe wie ein
gewöhnliches schlechtwetterprogramm
absolvieren
das technische museum ost island wo wir
schließlich landen ist eine eigenwillig
zusammengestellte sammlung von apparaten
maschinen und historischen
filmdokumenten er im museum von patrick
christiansen ist wo man sie nicht der
aktionskünstler der die halbe welt in
die luft sprengen will sondern der
stille beobachter
[Musik]
das ist ja wie ein teil geliebt besser
ist ein tegel wo man sie gelernte
bauzeichner war bis in die 90er jahre an
der kunstgewerbeschule in luzern dozent
seine leidenschaft für formen für das
elementare wird deutlich härter süden
oder aber der neue hat der faszination
extremsituation von menschen wieder
locken als ich musste kämpfen dass das
berührte marinieren menschen oder
nächste stein seit ich möchte nicht ganz
so oder lebensraum aber hier und da
komme gehören daher
[Musik]
disney stoppt trotz des heftigen
schneefalls macht sich die gruppe auf
die reise quer durch russland
mich interessiert hier oben in island
romantikers lebenslange suche nach dem
eigenen weg
der mann der lieber allein gelassen wird
und im tiefsten schneefall auf die
fahrkünste seines freundes vertraut der
mann scheint nämlich mit 75 noch auf der
suche zu sein
[Musik]
und wären wir durch die abgelegenen
straßen island fahren wird mir bewusst
wie schwierig das gewesen sein muss mit
dem eigenen weg in der schweiz der
späten 60er jahre
[Musik]
die schweizer kunstwelt hat ihn lange
nur belächelt
er lernte wohl in dieser zeit nur auf
sich und wenige freunde zu hören
die jeder künstler will doch ein wenig
dass man schwenkt und der maschinist und
du braucht jeder künstler braucht ja
zwei drei freunde oder aber sagen dass
interessanter macht
wenn du keine adresse zu der stadt
ziemlich trostlos schaff's nicht wenn
jemand dich akzeptiert oder und schnell
schafft es nicht weil sie angst nur zwei
drei kollegen die frau waren da und
konnte so weitermachen wird in island
taxi geflügel
ich kümmere mich der fahrer
ich weiß nicht was zuerst war war es der
appenzeller grint des jungen ziegner der
seinen eigenen weg suchte oder war es
die verletzte seele wie es in der enge
nicht mehr aushielt
ich spüre jetzt noch ein paar lichter im
wasserspringen begriff schachtel und
abgrund im tor nicht der puck
hör jetzt
bergsport
burger
wenig darauf gesehen
und da haben eine große unterstützung
mein vater selber künstler musiker bis
sie das toleriert und rückseite verstand
an verschiedene besucher auf dem konto
rashid wird davon
ramisch
denke ja gut
mach es mal wieder
die maschine konnte sturm
das unklar
mittlerweile kann sich segler mit dem
verkauf von kunstwerken und mit
kunstaktionen finanzieren
sammler sind bereit für einen echten
siegner einen stattlichen betrag
hinzublättern
wir sind in einem vulkan museum im
westen islams angelangt
der besitzer des museums ist der
vulkanologe harald kurzer er hat zwar
noch keinen sieg in seiner sammlung aber
eine theorie was künstler an vulkanen
fasziniert es ist die erhabenheit dieser
vulkane welche die künstler inspiriert
es ist ein unglaublich schönes ereignis
aber gleichzeitig furcht einflößen
vulkane sind an so schön und schrecklich
zugleich und sie sind so mächtig dass
der mensch auf gibt sich hingibt und
vielleicht schafft er es und überlegtes
und es entsteht kunst darauf während der
experte über die verschiedenen
vulkanausbrüche referiert konnte roman
signer ein alter brauch aus dem
appenzell in den sinn
die natur
so schön und grausam kann sie sein
aufbruch und zerstörung liegen hier in
island so nah beieinander
der künstler aus dem appenzell der eine
kunst macht die selber vergänglich ist
fühlt sich von diesem schauspiel
angezogen
dort wo es aus dem boden raucht und
kocht wird es zeit um mit dem 75
jährigen über die eigene vergänglichkeit
zu sprechen
deshalb lohne bildlich magazines natur
taxis oberrad natur wie sofort zerstörer
eigentlich lösungen auf bauten zerstört
der mensch alles natur scharfer tragen
heute verschwindet oder ja ich so was
macht ihnen angst nein ich mache krank
dann haben wir ziemlich gelassen
[Musik]
und dann steht der große tag bevor
frühmorgens hat es auf dem areal noch
keine touristen
[Musik]
der wunsch
am rand des kaisers etwas zu machen
begleitet die romantiker schon seit 20
jahren jetzt kurz vor seinem 75
geburtstag machte sich das geschenk
[Musik]
ein geschenk denke ich mir für sich aber
auch für das fernsehpublikum doch roman
sieger ist noch nicht zufrieden
er geht 3 schritte weiter nach vorn
[Musik]
diesen versuch mester gelten auch wenn
er sich dabei fast die füße verbrüht und
plötzlich merke ich wie mehr wo man
siegen aber diese aktion auch eine rolle
zu teilte so viele verschieden und noch
ums wasser
so dürfen oder problem werden
[Musik]
war es das also frage ich mich beim
weiterfahren
ein mann mit einem schirm neben einem
geysir sie deswegen einmal quer über die
insel gefahren
habe ich wirklich begriffen was er mit
der kunst sagen will
erst im hotelzimmer am abend ist hermann
ziegler bereits über den sinn und unsinn
seiner kunst zu sprechen aber für den
betrachter spiegelt landschaft und der
mensch ein schirm
immer wieder habe mir vorgestellt wie
gold und der künstlich ganz anders
wirklichkeit die tantrische man ganz
klar
und wer jetzt aber wirklich kritische
gehandelt
ja
und so endet diese reise und wo man
siegner gewährt mir noch einmal einen
letzten einblick in seine gedankenwelt
bürger aus
das gros der sound tag und nacht schafft
atlantik dem strom und manager nur
sekunden
ich habe wieder weg oder
denke der nacht im atlantik aktuelle
mittagessen natur vulkan uhr denke schon
und er schafft auch wenn jemand verrückt
oder immer trauen
steigende geschafft
[Musik]
die